[Música]
Hola Esto es África siete días un
programa semanal en el que analizamos la
actualidad más destacada del continente
africano Mi nombre es Y esto es lo que
veremos hoy
viajaron a kiev y después a San
Petersburgo Rusia una delegación de
presidentes y altos funcionarios
africanos intentó reconciliar al
presidente ruso Vladimir Putin y al
presidente ucraniano
y pocos días antes de la visita de esta
delegación el presidente ruso recibió al
presidente argelino App del boom argel y
Moscú firmaron un documento para
reforzar su cooperación estratégica
ya van dos meses en que las columnas de
humo oscurecen al cielo de jartum la
capital sudanesa y dos meses en que los
civiles soportan la guerra que se Libra
en el ejército y los paramilitares
[Música]
abrimos esta edición con los esfuerzos
de paz liderados por África en Ucrania
cuatro jefes de estado un Primer
Ministro y un enviado especial viajaron
a la capital ucraniana kiev y luego a
San Petersburgo en Rusia para intentar
mediar entre el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin y el presidente ucraniano
la delegación encabezada por el
mandatario sudafricano city la rama fosa
formuló propuestas que se resumen en los
siguientes puntos
la desescalada de ambas partes el
reconocimiento de la soberanía
establecida por la ONU las garantías de
seguridad para todas las partes el
levantamiento de las barreras a la
exportación de grano la liberación de
los prisioneros de guerra y la
reconstrucción
la cuestión de la exportación de
cereales es especialmente importante
para África que depende en gran medida
del trigo ucraniano y Ruso escuchemos
ahora la respuesta del presidente ruso a
esta iniciativa de paz africano
no fuimos nosotros sino los dirigentes
ucranianos quienes anunciaron que no
llevarían a cabo ninguna negociación es
más el actual presidente de Ucrania ha
firmado un decreto que prohíbe tales
negociaciones Así que comprendo su
preocupación la comparto Y por supuesto
estamos dispuestos a examinar todas sus
propuestas pero no nos hemos negado a
negociar la parte ucraniana es la que se
ha negado
Y antes que Putin el presidente
ucraniano cuyas fuerzas armadas se
encuentran en plena contraofensiva
también rechazó las propuestas de la
delegación
Me parece que esta persona Putin no está
a la altura porque no está dispuesta a
ver la paz quiere aniquilar y destruir
por completo el país de Ucrania si estas
son sus intenciones tengo muchas dudas
sobre las conversaciones y el diálogo
que podemos mantener con esta persona
él está actuando hoy como un terrorista
debemos mirar todo lo que ocurre con la
misma visión algunos de mis colegas
líderes africanos siguen describiendo
esta guerra como una crisis Incluso hoy
siguen haciéndolo públicamente y están
en su derecho pero eso demuestra que
nuestra valoración de la situación es
diferente
sin embargo el presidente sudafricano
Consideró que la misión de la delegación
ha tenido en impacto positivo
creo que nuestra misión tuvo impacto
obviamente su éxito real se medirá en
función del objetivo final de detener la
guerra pero el impacto que ha tenido es
que en primer lugar se nos ha escuchado
al ofrecer una perspectiva africana
sobre la guerra que está teniendo
Consecuencias negativas para nuestro
continente
Y en segundo lugar somos probablemente
el único grupo que ha conseguido que los
dos líderes en un breve espacio de
tiempo entiendan una propuesta y una
opinión muy firme sobre la necesidad de
poner fin a la guerra
Y antes del viaje de la delegación
africana a Rusia el presidente argelino
abdomen viajó a Moscú para reunirse con
Vladimir Putin los dos países que
siempre han sido aliados han renovado un
acuerdo de colaboración estratégica pero
la visita del presidente argelino
también pretendía tranquilizar a Moscú
veamos por qué
es la primera vez desde el viaje del ex
presidente de la cis bu teflica en 2008
que un mandatario argelino realiza una
visita oficial a Moscú durante tres días
ante el Magic debum se reunió con su
homólogo ruso Vladimir Putin los dos
presidentes firmaron un documento para
renovar su colaboración estratégica en
los ámbitos de la justicia las
telecomunicaciones la agricultura la
cultura los recursos hídricos y la
exploración espacial los intercambios
comerciales entre argel y Moscú se
acercan a los 3.000 millones de dólares
y la cooperación militar entre ambos
países es de largo plazo siendo el
ejército ruso el principal proveedor de
armas de Argelia
es uno de los tres principales socios
comerciales de Rusia en el continente
africano
de cara al futuro me gustaría subrayar
que esperamos verles en San Petersburgo
a finales de Julio para la segunda
Cumbre Rusia África
el tema de la guerra en Ucrania ha
estado presente durante el encuentro en
un momento en el que Argelia está
intensificando sus esfuerzos de
modernización militar el estancamiento
de las tropas de Moscú en Ucrania y su
impacto en la industria de defensa rusa
podría llevar a argel a recurrir a
Europa para la compra de armamento otro
ámbito en el que Argelia podría haber
intensificada sus relaciones con Europa
a riesgo de molestar a Moscú es el de la
energía el tema ha adquirido mayor
urgencia a medida que los europeos
buscan alternativas algas ruso en este
contexto la visita del jefe de estado
argelino a Rusia podría interpretarse
como un intento de tranquilizar a su
viejo Aliado Incluso el presidente
argelino declaró que quiere desempeñar
el papel de mediador entre kiev y
agradecemos a Argelia y al presidente de
Argelia su disposición a prestar algunos
servicios de mediación
agradezco su excelencia el presidente su
corazón generoso por haber aceptado la
posibilidad de mediar entre el país
amigo la federación rusa y Ucrania en
relación con el conflicto actual Le
agradezco esta confianza que será
apropiada otro tema tratado por los
líderes fueron la cuestión del Sáhara
occidental y la situación en el sajero
sobre los que expresaron sus puntos de
vista comunes Por último el jefe de
estado argentino agradeció también a su
homólogo ruso por su apoyo a la
candidatura de Argelia para ingresar en
los brics el grupo que reúne a los
principales países emergentes
cambiamos de tema tras dos meses de
mortíferos combates la perspectiva de
una solución negociada al conflicto en
Sudán se aleja el ejército regular lanzó
una contrao contra los paramilitares
pero a pesar de su Potencia de fuego
superior fue incapaz de derrotarlos Y
estos ocupan ahora la mayor parte de la
capital jartum y amplias franjas de la
región de darfur en el oeste del país
mientras el pueblo sudanés es la
principal víctima de esta situación
cientos de miles han huido y el resto
intenta sobrevivir durante semanas
Arabia Saudita y Estados Unidos mediaron
en las negociaciones entre ambas partes
pero las numerosas treguas anunciadas
casi nunca han sido respetadas hablamos
con Galindo responsable de África
Oriental para el medio en línea África
intelligence Esto es lo que nos dijo
que es una lucha por el poder y todo
indicaba que iba a haber una guerra y
ahora el punto de no retorno fue cruzado
los dos ejércitos luchan por el control
de Cartoon y por las llaves del poder
no hay ningún deseo de alto el fuego
Sencillamente Porque mientras uno de los
dos bandos no tenga digamos una
superioridad sobre el otro y no esté en
posición de fuerza para negociar e
imponer sus condiciones al otro lo más
probable por desgracia es que los
combates continúen
Así que puede haber todos los intentos
de mediación que se quiera pero mientras
no haya voluntad por parte de los dos
beligerantes No avanzaremos mucho
observadores temen que se produzca un
escenario como el que se ha estado
desarrollando durante más de una década
en Libia yemen o Siria y que la guerra
se haga ahora a Puerta cerrada en un
clima de indiferencia internacional
hay varios escenarios posibles no tengo
una bola de cristal Así que no voy a
aventurar ninguna proyección pero puedo
responder diciendo que incluso antes de
que estallara el conflicto Sudán ya
estaba dividido
[Música]
que siempre ha habido oposiciones entre
el centro y la periferia de Sudán ya se
ha dividido una vez puesto que Sudán del
sur formaba parte anteriormente de Sudán
no
te hacemos que la interferencia de
ciertas potencias de fuera de Sudán
también puede jugar en esta lógica y que
por el momento no hay salida a la crisis
y que si no hay salida a la crisis esta
sigue escalando sobre todo en darkfur
todos los peores escenarios son
concebibles
antes de cerrar esta edición algunos
datos sobre la situación en Sudán los
combates se han cobrado más de 2.000
vidas y en todo el país casi la mitad de
los 45 millones de sudaneses dependen
ahora de la ayuda humanitaria para
sobrevivir más de 2,2 millones de
personas han huido de sus hogares según
la obra organización internacional para
las migraciones y más de 530,000 de
estos desplazados se han refugiado en
países vecinos como Chad y Sudán del sur
así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa Gracias por acompañarnos nos
vemos la próxima semana
[Música]